this is the moment a people smuggler
discovered the bodies of 39 vietnamese
illegal immigrants
in the back of his lorry the 39 men
women and
children had all suffocated on a ferry
journey across the north sea
there's immigrants in the back but
they're they're all lying on the ground
this is serious and organized crime and
has resulted in the loss
on this case of 39 lives i can confirm
we have offices working around the clock
and we have now arrested a fourth person
they had been locked inside a sealed
container
with no fresh air for at least 12 hours
jurors were told of a smuggling network
that cashed in on migrants
desperate to reach the uk
in fact we know that two very similar
journeys had been completed
in the days before so why did this
particular journey end in tragedy for
the 39 migrants
and who's to blame for their deaths
it's tuesday morning on the 22nd of
october
just hours before the 39 vietnamese
would start the journey
that would lead to their deaths some of
the victims are in paris at this point
others in brussels
most had traveled separately from
vietnam months earlier
motivated by difficult economic
conditions back home
some borrowed thousands of pounds from
their families to get there
and told relatives they were taking a
vip
trip to england to find work
that will be the primary goal to come to
the uk to work hard
to send money home and then return back
to vietnam it's generally not just an
individual decision it's a decision that
will be made in consultation with the
entire family it was is a project that
takes many months
to plan to organize you know securing
the funds
you know migrants have to be determined
to do this
26 year fantae tarmee
was hoping to reach the uk to work in
the beauty industry
she had planned to send money home to
her family to pay off their debts
and fix up their house her parents
borrowed money to pay
for her trip by mortgaging their land
2019. travelling by bus to hanoi
and then by car to china from china
me then flew to france where the
smugglers had arranged to pick up the
migrants
at 9 27 a.m on the 22nd of october
three taxis pulled into the sherman
strata
in bien then at 10 19 a.m
eamon harrison pulled into the same spot
and got out for nine minutes
this is when the migrants are believed
to have climbed into the back of his
lorry
harrison said he'd been told to hide
inside his cab with the curtains closed
not available it collected and delivered
food and drink but at other times it
made
tens of thousands of pounds by smuggling
illegal immigrants into the uk
haulage boss ronan hughes was the
ringleader of the smuggling operation
and harrison had been in contact with
him that morning
at 11 30 am harrison drove his lorry
from the french border
into belgium the temperature in the
trailer
had now reached 21 degrees centigrade
and would continue to rise throughout
the journey
we know this because the migrants were
inside a refrigerator trailer
which was fitted with a device to record
temperatures
but the refrigeration was not on all the
time they were on board
if it's between 10 and 30 000
pounds that people are paying for that
journey that's amassing
anywhere between 45 million and 135
million
for the criminals and then there is the
additional sums of money
that are earned by criminals when the
people arrive either in the uk or
somewhere else in europe
when they're in these exploitative
situations whether it's cannabis farms
car washes
nail bars and of course when they arrive
in the uk there is a backlog of debts
and exploitation and a load of people
who they've got to
you know resolve the situations with
whether that's payments or promises
or helping out in some other way
harrison arrived at zebra port with the
trailer shortly after 1pm
but he then turned around and drove
south to a petrol station
outside the village of lissaweger
harrison went into a shop and bought a
can of drink
the temperature inside the trailer was
now 25.2
centigrade harrison drove back to
zbrugger
and entered the port just after 1 40 pm
he reversed the trailer uncoupled it and
drove away
eamonn harrison's job was done the team
in the uk were waiting for their
instructions
the trailer was loaded onto a ship
called the clementine
which set off 36 minutes late
as the ship steamed towards england the
migrants were trapped
inside the trailer in total darkness
with no way of opening the doors
because there are so many links in that
journey there's so many
sort of possibilities for things to go
wrong
for exploitation to take place for abuse
to take place
those journeys can be very very
dangerous and precarious for these
migrants
by 6 25 pm the temperature had risen to
almost
35 degrees inside and selfies taken by
fam tatami reveal the sweltering
conditions the migrants were facing
we can't show these images because
they're too distressing
over the next couple of hours the
migrants tried desperately to phone for
help
but there was no signal inside the
trailer
one of the victims dialed 113 the number
for the emergency services in vietnam
but the call didn't go through
fam tatami tried to make phone calls at
701
702 703 and 704 pm
but none of them were successful
meanwhile
in essex those awaiting the lorry
trailer's arrival in england
were making their plans
ronan hughes had sent morris robinson
the lorry driver on the english side
a message with further details by
picking up the migrants from perfleet
ferry terminal
robinson was set to make almost sixty
thousand pounds
at 7 37 pm the temperature inside the
trailer
had climbed to 36 degrees centigrade
the migrants began to record messages to
their loved ones
i'm sorry i can't take care of you i'm
sorry i'm sorry
i cannot breathe said knewing tatong
i cannot breathe i'm sorry i have to go
now
said nuing dun lung two minutes later
the same victim said
i'm sorry it's all my fault
the temperature was still rising and by
902 pm
it had reached 38 degrees centigrade
between 10 and 10 30 pm the carbon
dioxide in the trailer is thought to
have reached a toxic
threshold so many migrants could no
longer survive in the airtight container
they would have suffocated shortly after
the clementine arrived at per perfleet
just after midnight
maurice robinson had already arrived and
was waiting to collect the trailer
according to the prosecution romanian
george nika was also in the area
and ready to carry out his part of the
plot
jurors were told his role was to
organize transport for the immigrants
once they were unloaded from the lorry
nika admitted
previous people smuggling but he denied
having a role in the deaths of the
migrants
as the containers were taken off the
ship and moved to shore
a cargo operator said he noticed a
decomposing smell
coming from the trailer similar to waste
morris robinson collected the trailer
and drove out of the port
just after one o'clock his instructions
were to drive to the area of collingwood
farm in orset
where said the prosecutor george nika
and the other drivers were waiting
instead robinson turned into eastern
avenue in thorac
after receiving a new instruction
give them air quickly but don't let them
out
ronan hughes sent robinson this message
on snapchat
hughes was right to be concerned given
the number of people they had smuggled
in the trailer
but it was too late shortly before 1 15
am
robinson opened the rear door of the
trailer slightly
he took a step back and stood there for
90 seconds
as vapor rose from the lorry then he
went back to the driver's seat
the first thing robinson did after he
discovered the dead bodies
was to call ronan hughes
it wasn't until 23 minutes later
after first driving off and then
returning to the same spot
that robinson rang 999.
hello caller is patient breathing hello
uh no i'm a lorry driver and i just
lifted a trailer from
the port okay is the patient breathing
no there
there's uh loads of them but there's
immigrants in the back but they're
they're all lying on the ground okay
they're breathing
i don't think so they're not breathing
don't think so no
okay tell me exactly what's happened i
went and lifted a trailer from
uh perfectly the freight terminal
yeah and i got round to where i was
gonna park up for the night
yeah and i heard it i heard the noise in
the back and i opened the door and
there's a bunch of them how many
approximately
the trailers jammed i i don't know tell
me approximately how many patients
uh 20 phase
25 patients not breathing yeah yeah
when police arrived at the scene at 1 50
am
one of the trailer doors was open and
officers could see
numerous half-naked bodies on the floor
they were motionless close to one
another
some were frothing at the mouth there
was condensation coming from the back of
the lorry
and a smell like chemicals pc jack
emerson tried to check for signs of life
on all the bodies he
could reach but because they were so
tightly packed
this was difficult and we begin
with breaking news 39 people including a
teenager
have been found dead inside a lorry
container at an industrial park
in essex all such traders in human
beings
should be hunted down and brought to
justice as news of the tragedy broke
around the world
christopher kennedy one of the alleged
lorry drivers from previous trips
was asked by a friend about the 39
deaths
his alleged reply must have been too
many
and ran out of air kennedy who was not
there on the night
denied being part of a wider people
smuggling plot
the court heard that the week before his
lorry was stopped at calais by border
officials
they found 20 vietnamese migrants on
board
and released them at least two of the
migrants from that foiled trip
died in harrison's lorry a week later
now at the moment
if you look globally only one victim
in every 2150 sees their perpetrator
convicted that's shockingly low
99.98 of the time i think the figures
are that you get away with this
so if you're a criminal committing these
crimes there's nothing stopping you
there's nothing pushing you back
because you're making you know globally
150 billion us dollars a year is the
estimate
a lot of that comes from the uk why
would you not do this crime
the prosecution said the smugglers
simply doubled up the number of
migrants they got too greedy
that greed cost 39 lives
and left the families of those victims
in vietnam
devastated
in vietnam huang van tipp's parents
visited their son's grave
and lit incense for him
he was 18 years old
for the vietnamese burning incense is a
sacred practice
it helps connect the living world with
the dead
knewing van home's parents also lit
incense for their son
they say they don't want to talk about
him anymore
it's too painful
going back there to glen it's a clean
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you